a mindset that is more humanistic more
more
more centralized on heart set and and
mindset
and connection rather than ego and me
more about wheat than me
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me all the
way from australia how are you doing
hey mike we're really good it's really
good to see you really good to see you
really good to see you have you been
doing this cover and you're
originally from greece now and you're in
australia what's happening with you
it's a bit mixed up i know but we can
get there so i started off from here
actually on melbourne born and raised
and i moved across to greece about three
or four years ago now to do some work
there with uh marine traffic
and i came here back to australia in in
feb in la feb but i've been locked in
with the lock down
ever since so i'm not going anywhere in
a hurry and look i'm
i'm happy to be back here it's a it's a
great country as you'd appreciate
um and i just work remotely so we're
making it work
i love it i love it okay great so you
know over these next 20 minutes i'm
really excited to talk about a variety
of things
that we've already started discussing
before we started sharing this episode
about this idea of dealing through
adversity uh leading through crisis
and particularly um you know also what
you're doing with marine traffic so nico
i'd love you to tell me a little bit
about
where you started where your journey to
a queue and and then we'll transition
off to the entrepreneurial stuff
okay so um i i started off uh in the
media and i worked in the media for
about five years and it was an amazing
experience because i got a couple of
stories and really
interact with people from all walks of
life
but it was at a time when believe it or
not the internet was just starting to
have
on on media it was in the late 90s and
you could see the landscape changing
very very quickly so i want to do
something different and one thing i
learned very early on
is our ability to be relevant
depends on our ability to disrupt
ourselves so the more often we can
disrupt our own trajectory that ensures
greater relevance in the world and the
space that we find ourselves in
so when i wrapped up with media i i fell
into pharmaceuticals
and i spent 15 years in the world of
farmer working for a
yeah an american multinational company
based in chicago
and they were absolutely brilliant so i
worked in leadership
um in in pharma really understanding how
to build a business how to engage with
customers
strategy marketing wow all the great
things that you
get to learn from a multinational group
like
like a huge pharma company um in the
last five years of my time in pharma
what i could see though was big
corporate business
and the way that it was structured
versus
this ecosystem that was emerging around
the world this ecosystem that was very
innovative and disruptive and i had a
really good energy about it
and almost like an attitude of anything
is possible
just watch us and we'll make it happen
and i was really really attracted to
that
because what i found was working for a
big company as good as it was
in the initial stages that it was slow
to move
and we weren't actually responding but
we were
reacting to change and and that was a
real problem as we know now
so what i did in within the last five
years i
i discovered co-working when i was in
new york i went into one of the original
we work spaces
um in downtown new york there's a story
there
um and i i thought great i could do this
in australia so
i launched a couple of co-working spaces
in australia well
here here in melbourne yeah um they were
very intimate so
it was designed to be uh quite
collaborative
but what it did as we manage these
spaces in these spaces grew
it exposed me to this almost like
uh it was almost like alice falling into
this black hole of uh
wonderland um of all these startups and
tech
and bloggers and vloggers and you name
it people
earning income and making a living in a
very different way to what i had been
trained or accustomed to doing and
you know michael it really excited me
and it enthused me so
i did that for the last five years and
obviously that got me into all these
startup events
i became an ambassador for startup grind
and i
continued throwing myself into the
startup community understanding
how it worked and and and
the opportunity that existed in the
world that was changing super
super fast and all i knew was that i
didn't want to miss out
i wanted to be part of the change i
wanted to be part of the world i didn't
want to be relevant
and not being irrelevant meant
constantly getting out of my comfort
zone to learn new things and challenge
myself
and feel uncomfortable more so often
than not
wow that's okay so you're starting off
all the way in
in media you're finding yourself in
pharmaceuticals in a big company you're
realizing that
there's all these great changes and a
big company might be
might be slow to move and you're
transitioning all of a sudden to
co-working spaces and starting
co-working spaces
in australia and you're getting exposed
to all these startups
so far so far correct so far spot-on
startup grind and and now you're
realizing okay your your passion lies
and
and seeing these changes unfold dealing
through these adversities and
discovering new realms
how do you find yourself then in marine
technology and marine traffic
yeah it's crazy it's been an amazing
ride um so i did some i did a brief
stint with a health tech startup here in
melbourne
um and whilst i was doing that i was
given a chance to do um
head of sales innovation role for uh for
a fashion brand
which i'd never done before and it was
an amazing experience
but when i left that i started my own
consultancy i really wanted to do
something
for myself and whilst traveling
being lucky enough to travel around the
world um remember these things called
aeroplanes that we can't get into
anymore um
i used to basically live in one um i got
to meet
um the ceo of marine traffic who to be
honest at the time i didn't know a lot
about the company i had a really i've
got a really good friend of mine who
works for the organization
organization and he did say to me he
goes you guys need to get together
um because i could see so many
commonalities between the two of you and
we did get together
and we had an amazing conversation um
and that conversation spurred some work
that i did for marine traffic as a
independent consultant and then that
results into the role that i'm currently
doing now and i'm just so
super humble to be able to support an
ever-growing team in maritime technology
and the fact that it's a start-up that
emanated from greece at a time when
greece was in financial
turmoil i think that in itself is an
amazing story
wow okay so so you know i hear a lot
about non-linear trajectories and
non-linear paths to career
and i don't know if i've heard as many
that come close to what you're
describing here
now talk to me a little bit about the
about about maritime technology marine
marine technology and greece during the
economic crisis
you know i'm assuming that you're
talking about you know looking at 2008
onwards
and what's happening with with marine
technology and why are you excited about
that now
so super excited it's an amazing space
like when you consider that 80 to 85
percent of all the goods around us have
been transported to us by
shipping can you quickly understand the
level of depth that
shipping has and the role the important
role that it plays
in our lives um so that was one thing
the technology itself
then i i learned about the story of
marine traffic
and it started off as a passion project
by our founder mrs
and he's a professor at the eugene
university and what he did was he
created a global community
a global community of shipping
enthusiasts and what he did he sent out
ais transponders
around the world where people place them
in strategic positions and then we
picked up data
and that data now became the platform
that is known as
marine traffic providing different
layers of information to people from all
walks of life
every single day and critical
information as we saw
overnight with the with the explosion in
beirut and lebanon
it was marine traffic data that was able
to actually stick together
the journey of of of the ship that that
had
the components that cause the the
explosion so
shipping technology touches on so many
different parts
it's the retrospective data that we have
but it's also the data
that can improve efficiency in shipping
full stop and that's really really
exciting
so so is that really is are the use
cases mainly focused on on efficiency
and optimization or more about security
and and knowledge where where does the
sort of big value lie
in having this data all of the above
all of the above uh because it's
different strokes for different folks
and different
company businesses have very different
needs
so we've got to understand that when it
comes to shipping
it's an industry that for many many
years was actually untouched
by technology so the the progress that
we had seen in other spaces didn't exist
in this space
so all of a sudden you've had this
massive
investment in shipping technology that
has really changed the way shipping is
and will be
forever and that's really exciting to be
able to be part of that
now when you're saying shipping
technology i'm assuming it's not
necessarily that the ships are changing
but it's about
how do we monitor these ships how do we
optimize the space that we that we store
on these ships
and how do we decide which ship takes
where and what journey they do right
michael it's a bit of both as well
because not only do we have shipping
intelligence that actually gives us
different layers of data
as to how shipping operates around the
world but we're also at a day and age
now we're looking at autonomous shipping
you know shipping without anyone just
basically carrying
cargo around the world so exciting times
that that that we need are there
literally ships with
autonomous ships that have nobody on
them right now
yeah so in testing yeah absolutely
absolutely very you know it just dawned
on me that this term
shipping you know we use it and we use
it interchangeably now with any good
that is being transferred from one place
to another
or you know we want to ship a product
but but it's i guess it stems from the
fact that
everything was is done by ships right
you're saying 80 or 85 percent of the
things are actually done by ships
so it's not making a lot a lot of sense
so so where it so
it sounds like you know we are in this
in this exciting time where
where maritime technology is becoming
more and more relevant and more startups
are going into it
it sounds to me pretty obvious that if
80 or 85 percent of goods are
transferred through ships
this should have been one of the first
industries to be able to utilize big
data but it sounds like
that wasn't necessarily the case there
weren't many entrepreneurs going into
that field in the first place
and and that's a really good point i
think maybe there was an eagerness for
entrepreneurs to to break in
but like any industry when an industry
is set in its ways it's really hard and
it's working
and it's working for the people and the
key players within that industry it's
really hard to really drive the change
but at some point something starts to
break
and when it starts to break and it's not
working as efficiently as it once did
that's the catalyst for change so it's
probably almost like a perfect storm
michael as we know
it was a product market fit where
something wasn't working and they became
apparent then all of a sudden the need
for technology
in this case became more real and more
relevant
wow okay so now talk to me a little bit
about dealing with adversity
and dealing with difficulties especially
through a covet we mentioned this before
but i'd love to hear a little bit about
your take and your and your leadership
journey there
look it's been an amazing journey for
everyone over the last few months and
who knows what happens next and
up until now though as an organization
as a team
i've got to say like i'm really proud of
the way that we um and
our team have managed through this uh
over the last few months
um it's been incredible um one thing
that we did
was it was quite prophetic actually in
january every january we have our
kickoff summits so we fly in our team
from all over the world
into the heart of athens and we have a
kickstarter to the
strategy marketing and time for us to
bond and get together
wow during the last day during the last
day of this
team team meeting that that we run um we
had
we had a pandemic we had h1n1
breakout so about 10 of our team members
got sick during this process
so what we then did was in january now
we had to lock down
our officers uh to invert obviously the
spread
now that was basically a practice run
for what was to come only like a month
and a half later
so when we when we and because we were
following this situation from warhand
we're keeping a very close eye on the
situation
when we could see things at the tipping
point just before they tipped over
um we called it we called it so we
actually shut our offices down very very
quickly we communicated with our team
very openly
and we sent everyone home as the
dispersed team to work from wherever
they live
anywhere in the world and i think taking
action early on and being on top of it
was really really important particularly
because it's such an unknown
scary situation the next thing we did
michael was
we called uh fortnightly meetings which
we still do they're global team
check-ins
and it's a chance to just get together
and at times there may not be anything
new to say
but the fact that we're together and see
each other on screen
um and we have a bit of a laugh a bit of
banter is really really important
because they're the
water cooler conversations that we can
no longer physically have together
and it's not until people connect with
the team the way you do remotely that
you really understand and feel how
how much the people that you work with
really mean to you
and what role what massive role they
play
in in each of our lives so so having our
meetings um fortnightly with the global
team was really really important
very quickly as well we also formed the
crisis management team and the crisis
management team which i'm part of as
well
was all about assessing the situation on
a weekly basis you know
what are the hotspots what are we doing
what are scenarios that we should
should be exploring in scenarios
scenario planning
it was really really important that we
kept it very simple because
this can play out in so many different
ways it gets super confusing so we only
ever focused on one two or three
scenarios
max and were usually pretty much in uh
in the right area but fundamentally
apart from all the logistical stuff
the most important thing that we were
doing was maintaining human connection
maintaining connection through through
dialogue through
conversations to slack uh through
phone calls that would that that have
with our team um or through google
hangouts discussions
and their one-on-ones and maintaining
that even to this day
and beyond something we will continue to
do is really
really important because people work
with people people connect
with people and we as humans give each
other greater purpose
and fun so ensuring that people are
feeling safe and secure
tick tick huge priorities for us um but
maintaining this
you know being able to look at people
and see how they're feeling and asking
questions behind the questions and all
that
was super important has been our saving
grace it hasn't been easy
it hasn't been because even leaders have
have their moments
as well and i i read somewhere recently
that
um the role of leader in a crisis is to
absorb
fear and exude hope and i
i really really believe that um at times
though
even even the leader can be a little bit
shaken and i think it's really important
for for everyone to hear that and
understand that because
at times and i'm guilty of it too we may
put unrealistic expectations
on our leaders and what our leaders
should be doing next and what they
should know and what we expect of them
and if this situation teaches us
anything it should teach us a shifting
mindset
you know a mindset that is more
humanistic
more more more centralized on heart set
and and mindset and connection rather
than
ego and me more about wheat than me
i love it that's that's just incredible
by the way how did the team react
when already you know a month before the
rest of the world you're shutting down
essentially you're doing something that
even in march i remember that when when
you know we i left stanford campus in
mid-march and we
said okay yeah we're coming back in you
know in a week or two after spring break
and then they said no you're not we were
like wow this is this is crazy we can't
even believe it
i can only imagine the reaction that you
know people might have had
you know back in february or january
when you're making these decisions when
the world is still not talking
about covert 19 right well and
and maybe i misled you so what we did
was we we shut down in in january
on the back of our uh our own pandemic
of h1n1 infection
within our company so we shut down for
about a week and a half but then we
really opened
so when when we so when we monitored the
situation and we could see
uh see things moving very very quickly
we were able to quickly shut down again
for the second time this time because of
covert not because
okay so you had so you had that
experience and you had that and and you
were able then to
to to adapt quickly and the team members
already knew the protocol so it was a
little bit less of a shock factor
than than perhaps for others moving
forward
i mean what what do you see happening
both with your organization but but
overall in
in the world of of of technology and
tech you know as you're experiencing it
obviously you're you're
you're in the forefront as a leader
leading a team through this crisis
you obviously have to prepare now for
for years to come
both in terms of of work from home but
also in terms of you know running a
company
in this new mindset so how well how are
you even you know approaching this
look it that's a really good question
and it's a very interesting situation
that we all face um and it's interesting
because michael like we've been
accustomed to
um instant gratification yeah there's a
problem let's fix
it we're back to normal and i know
people don't want to
hear the term but we're entering the
unknown it's a it's
it's it and that's the new normal you
know the new normal is to
totally expect the unexpected and you
know i think about generations before us
who've gone through
real hardship through walls through
famine through
through difficult life-changing events
and what those events taught them at the
time
was resilience and the power to be able
to
have a centered perspective and move on
step by step
our generation right here right now we
want instant gratification we want okay
covert right let's get over it let's
move on let's get back to how we were
firstly i think that's a waste of a
crisis
a total waste of the crisis if we're
yearning to go
back to what we were i could think of
nothing worse like
we've learned something you know we've
gained something so let's redesign it
let's
rethink it let's move on to something
that could be better than what it was
but it's human nature uh
to feel safe and secure to gravitate to
what makes us
feel safe and secure and that is the
past but in this case we need to let it
go
because as you said and i totally agree
with you what we're experiencing is not
going to last for a few months it will
last for a number of years
if we're lucky if we're lucky so what do
i think will happen
when you consider the mumps i know funny
thing that
mumps um it took them four years to
develop the vaccine for it to go to
market and that was
the whole world working together to
actually develop a vaccine
now that was in the 60s admittedly we've
moved on in leaps and bounds in terms of
taking science and fungus since then
i get it but we still need to go through
four phases of trials
which includes human testing at the end
of it before we even have a vaccine
so let's not wait for that silver bullet
to come
instead let's redesign our own pathway
so companies like google and uber as we
know
have already announced a work remote
plan at least until june july 2021
right so firstly i think it's really
important to be able to give
your team a company a bit of a timeline
a bit of an understanding that
hey this isn't going to be quickly fixed
that we're going to need
time and in that time all we can ask
is a constant flow of open and honest
transparent communication
people feel unsafe people
um lose their balance when the
communication stops
and even if there's nothing new to say
like i said earlier
there's nothing new to say maintaining
that communication is really important
so for us
we have a plan over the next few months
and what we're doing we're monitoring
the situation as i mentioned earlier
and in september we're getting together
our crisis management team
and we'll assess the situation at the
time to make a decision
as to what we need to do between
september and december
um having said that our summer for 2021
is in january again
and it'll probably be virtual so we look
we're planning a virtual summit and
we're
excited to be doing that but you know
what this opportunity in that because
we've reached out to some
amazing global speakers that ordinarily
we would not have access to
so always
[Music]
now the other thing that i just want to
mention is the the mental health
challenge that
we all face during this time of
quarantine and isolation feeling the way
that we're feeling
um one of the things that we did very
early on this year is we employed a
full-time psychologist
in our team really yeah and she's an mt
coach
and every single one of our team members
has unlimited access
to our nt coach whenever he or she
needs to have a chat whether it's
personal or professional
um she's there we're there to help
together with our people operations
that's just remarkable i just i'm so
inspired by by your take on it and your
ex
you know the excitement that you're
bringing to the table with this change
and saying yes
it we have this issue we don't we don't
know what's happening it's it's really
it's really problematic but we're we're
extremely excited about
you know the different opportunities
that it presents and we're always
looking at the at the upside of it so i
think that
i think this that's just a remarkable
way to go and i'm and i can only imagine
that
everybody who works with you in this
company it can only feel this
the same excitement for for dealing with
this adversity and dealing with the
challenges
and and the fact that i agree that
knowing the timeline and having these
expectations and already planning
you know a virtual summit for next year
i'm sure that it gives some sort of
confidence to the team that's saying
well you know we we know some things we
don't know a lot of things but but our
leadership
is guiding us towards some reality that
we're that we can be confident in and i
think that's wonderful
nicole before we leave i have to ask you
for my favorite question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
sure done all right okay i think first
and foremost empathetic
um i feel joy i feel pain i feel
i feel what you're feeling and i that
gives me a real
heightened sense of experience and and i
love that because it really aids with
with connection so definitely empathetic
i'm
super super curious i always want to
learn and throw myself into the most
challenging situations people who know
me very well go like you're crazy you're
crazy
how can you do that but i do it i do it
because i'm curious
and i think that also leads into being
adventurous
i love adventure i love throwing myself
into a plane and
going to countries that i've never been
to before not knowing a single soul
and then walking away with amazing best
mates that are with me for life so
i think those three words to wrap to
describe
nico thank you very very much this was
inspiring i enjoyed it so so much
best of luck with everything and i look
forward to continue watching and
it's watching the company grow and
watching your your
non-linear career proceed because it's
just it's remarkable thank you very much
thank you michael thank you take care